welcome here to bethesda game studios
it's amazing to think it has only been a
year since you first heard about fallout
4 at this very event and thanks to you
it became not just our most popular game
ever but one of the industry's it has
simply blown us away and we're
incredibly blessed to have fans like you
seeing what you've created not just in
the main game with the add-ons and of
course mods it is just incredible and
we're not done yet we're excited to show
you what's coming next for Fallout 4
it's all over but the crying and I can
Oh
of course we didn't just announced
fallout 4 last year we also announced
and released fallout shelter which over
50 million of you have downloaded and
played we have a really big update
coming out take a look
Oh
we hope you're as excited as we are
about all of the stuff coming to fall
out we want to thank you again not just
for your support over the last year but
your support of our whole studio really
over the last 20 years there is
something else though that you've been
asking us about and yes we've been
working on it
Oh